S
IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS
RAMPING UP THE RAGE OF THE
SUPREME COURT AFTER A BOMB SHELL
LAKE INDICATED THAT THE HIGH
COURT IS READY TO STRIKE DOWN
ROE V. WADE.
PROTESTERS TAKING TO THE STREETS
IN MAJOR LIBERAL CITIES CHANTING
"WE WON'T GO BACK."
SOME CLASHING WITH THE L.A.P.D.
POLICE SAY A GROUP THROUGH ROCKS
AND BOTTLES AT THE OFFICERS.
ONE COP WAS INJURED.
TOP DEMOCRATS ECHOING THE FURY
COMING FROM THE BASE.
>> THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT THINK THEY CAN
IMPOSE THEIR RELIGIOUS VIEWS AND
ALL OF THE WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY
AND THEY ARE WRONG.
HOW DARE THEY TRY TO STOP US
FROM DETERMINING HER OWN FUTURE.
HOW DARE THEY TRY TO DENY WOMEN
THEIR RIGHTS AND THEIR FREEDOMS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN ADDING FUEL
TO THE FIRE AND DUBBING SOME
SERIOUS ATTACKS OF REPUBLICANS.
>> THIS IS ABOUT A LOT MORE THAN
ABORTION.
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU HAVE STATES
CHANGE THE LAWS SAYING THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE LGBTQ CAMPING
CLASSROOMS WITH OTHER CHILDREN?
IS THAT LEGIT.
WHAT ARE THE NEXT THINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE ATTACKED?
THIS IS REALLY THE MOST EXTREME
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
EXISTED.
>> Dana: JUDGE I WANT TO START
WITH THAT.
THERE'S THIS IDEA THAT THIS LEFT
IS PUSHING THAT THE
SUPREME COURT NEXT ARE GOING TO
BAN INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE.
WHAT THAT WOULD BE VERY STRANGE
FOR CLARENCE THOMAS TO DO.
>> I AGREE WITH THIS.
LOOK, ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN AND
THE DEMS THE SKY IS FALLING.
THIS IS FOR THEM THE WORST
THING -- THEY CAN PREDICT
ANYTHING WILL HAPPEN AND THEY
WILL USE THIS AS A REASON TO
FIRE UP THEIR BASE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOTHING GOING FOR THEM IN
THE MIDTERMS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, GRISWOLD VERSUS
CONNECTICUT, LOVING VERSUS JUST
VIRGINIA, ALL OF THOSE OTHER
CASES, ALITO WAS VERY CLEAR IN
THE DECISION.
WE EMPHASIZE OUR DECISION
RECOGNIZE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION AND NO OTHER
RIGHT PAID NOTHING IN THIS
OPINION SHOULD BE UNDERSTOOD
CANCEL OUT OTHER PRECEDENTS THAT
DO NOT CONCERN ABORTION.
HE MAKES IT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
ABORTION.
IN ADDITION SOME OF THOSE OTHER
RIGHTS ARE BASED ON EQUAL
PROTECTION.
CIVIL RIGHTS, NOT NECESSARILY ON
THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
THAT SHOULD ALL BE REVOKED FROM
THE DISCUSSION OF THIS CASE.
>> Dana: GERALDO, WE HAVE NOT
HAD A CHANCE TO HEAR FROM YOU ON
THE SHOW THIS WEEK, WE'LL GIVE
YOU THE FLOOR.
>> Geraldo: I THINK FIRST OF
ALL REPUBLICANS MAKE A MISTAKE
WHEN THEY EMPHASIZED THE CRIME
OF THE LEAK ITSELF OVER THE
IMPACT OF WHAT THE DECISION
WOULD ENTAIL FOR THE WOMEN.
I THINK THAT EMOTION, HOWEVER
YOU THINK OF THOSE PARTICULAR
PERSONALITIES, THAT IS
LEGITIMATE.
THIS IS MORE PROBLEMATIC I
THINK, AND JUDGE I THINK YOU
WOULD AGREE WITH ME, BECAUSE IT
GOES BOTH WAYS.
WHAT THIS SHOWS IS THAT THE
SENATE CONFIRMATION PROCESS BY
WHICH A NOMINEE IS INTERROGATED
BY BOTH PARTIES AND GIVE THEIR
REASONS WHY THEY ARE FIT TO BE
ON THE HIGH COURT, IS ABSOLUTELY
DEEPLY FLAWED.
WHY?
BECAUSE THESE NOMINEES LIED.
THEY GO BEFORE THE SENATE OF THE
UNITED STATES, THEY SWEAR THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO BE JUDICIOUS
AND GOOD SHEPHERDS OF THE COURT
AND IMPARTIALITY IN THE
IMPORTANCE IT HAS IN THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY, AND THAT THE
STAR A DECISIVE SAYS, THE
PRESIDENT OF THESE CASES AS WELL
ESTABLISHED.
30 YEARS, 40 YEARS, 49 YEARS,
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THE
SUPREME COURT HONORS.
THEN THEY TURN AROUND THE MINUTE
THEY GET IN THE HIGH COURT THEY
MAKE A DECISION THAT IS SO
DRAMATICALLY OPPOSED TO WHAT
THEY SAID DURING THE
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS, SHAME ON
THEM.
SHAME A NEIL GORSUCH, SAME SHAME
ON AMY CONEY BARRETT.
THEY KNEW WHEN THEY WERE
SWEARING TO THOSE SENATORS AND
THE CONVERSATIONS IN THE SENATE
OFFICES THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
VOTE TO REVERSE, OR OVERTURN
ROE V. WADE WHERE THEY KNEW IT
AND THEY LIED ABOUT IT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FIX THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN REPAIR
WHEN THE MOST SACRED OFFICE IN
THE LAND, THE HIGH COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES, IS PEOPLED BY
POLITICIANS.
>> Dana: IF I WAS ACCUSED OF
BEING A SERIAL BECAUSE I LIKE
BEER AT 60 AND I WOULD SAY
WHATEVER I WANT TO GET OUT OF
THAT BUILDING.
>> Dana: LET ME DISAGREE.
YOU SAID I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU.
I ABSOLUTELY DO NOT AGREE WITH
YOU.
THERE WAS NO LINE TO THE SENATE
ON THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT STARE DECISIS.
STARE DECISIS MEANS THAT YOU
FOLLOW PRECEDENT.
THEY WERE CLEARED TO SAY THIS IS
NOT ONE OF THOSE SUPER DUE
PROCESS CASES LIKE BOARD --
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION
BOARD OF EDUCATION THAT
OVERTURNED PLESSY V. FERGUSON
SEPARATE BUT EQUAL.
THEY WERE VERY CLEAR.
ESPECIALLY AMY CONEY BARRETT.
SHE WAS CLEARED TO SAY STARE
DECISIS MEANS THAT THE COURTS
UNDER US HAVE TO RESPECT OUR
DECISION IS A SUPREME COURT, THE
HIGHEST COURT IN THE LAND.
AND THUS IT IS SUPER DUE
PROCESS, UNLESS IT IS LIKE BROWN
VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION WHERE
YOU CANNOT SEPARATE A WHITE AND
BLACK CHILDREN THEN WE CAN
DECIDE BASED ON WHAT COMES
BEFORE US.
>> Geraldo: FIVE HAVE THREE
DAUGHTERS IN THE STATE OF OHIO
IN THE FETAL HEARTBEAT LAW THAT
WILL NOW BE IN THAT PLACE, IT
WILL NOT BE THE LAW OF THE STATE
OF OHIO.
WHAT AM I GOING TO TELL MY
DAUGHTERS NOW?
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER THEIR BODY?
THAT THEY CAN'T MAKE THOSE
CHOICES FOR THEMSELVES?
THAT'S OLD MAN SCRATCHING HIS
BELLY AND SOME OTHER STATE IS
GOING TO SAY THAT --
>> AMY CONEY BARRETT IS NOT AN
OLD MAN.
>> LET'S LISTEN TO SOME MEDIA
RESPONSES TO ALL OF THIS IF WE
COULD.
>> THE FOUNDING FATHERS DIDN'T
RECOGNIZED ABORTION IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT BECAUSE THE
FOUNDING FATHERS WERE RACIST
MISOGYNISTIC JERK FACES.
>> I THINK WE ARE ALL INVITED TO
QUESTION THE LEGITIMACY OF --
>> SO DON'T THINK THIS IS JUST A
WAR ON WOMEN.
IT COULD BE A WAR ON PEOPLE OF
COLOR, AND GSY PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY
PRO-LIFERS WIN, BECAUSE THEY CAN
STATE THEIR HOPELESS CASE SO
PLAINLY.
YOU ASK SOMEBODY WHY THEY ARE
PRO-LIFE THEY WILL SAY BECAUSE
ABORTION TAKES A LIFE AND WE
BELIEVE LIFE IS SACRED.
YOU COULD DISAGREE WITH THAT,
BUT YOU CANNOT DISAGREE WITH THE
SIMPLICITY OF IT.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE
PRO-CHOICERS AS THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE BALLS TO STATE THEIR CASE
PLAINLY.
LIKE I PREFER FREEDOM OVER
FETUSES.
DON'T SIT HERE AND SAY I COME
UP -- LIKE IT'S GOING TO BE
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE NEXT.
>> Geraldo: MY BODY MY CHOICE
HOW MUCH SIMPLER COULD YOU GET?
>> Greg: LET ME FINISH.
YOU INSULTED A FEW PEOPLE THERE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS, PEOPLE ARE
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THEY
LOSE AND WHAT THEY WILL GAIN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE LOSS.
ALL YOU HAVE TO TO US TALK TO
SOMEBODY WHO LOST A CHILD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE IT,
IT'S THERE FOREVER.
A PRO-CHOICE MOM CAN LOOK AT HER
ADORABLE 2-YEAR-OLD AND THINK MY
LIFE WOULD BE NOTHING WITHOUT
HER 2022.
IN 2017, WHEN SHE WAS YOUNG AND
SINGLETON DIDN'T HAVE A KIT YOU
CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE LOSS OF HER
FREEDOM, RIGHT?
SO THAT'S THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO IMAGINE -- THEY CANNOT
STEP BACK AND SEE HOW PRO-CHOICE
ARGUMENTS ARE DRIVEN BY REFUSAL
TO IMAGINE WHAT THAT BABY COULD
BE.
BUT THEN WHEN THAT BABY BEES,
THEN SUDDENLY A CHANGE IS,
RIGHT?
AND THEY HAVE TO CREATE REASONS,
THEY HAVE TO CRATE ALL OF THESE
REASONS TO BE PRO-CHOICE.
RATHER THAN JUST BE HONEST AND
SAY YES IT KILLS AN UNBORN KID
BUT I PREFER MY FREEDOM.
THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO SAY.
YOU'LL GET SO MUCH MORE RESPECT.
THE OTHER THING THAT DRIVES ME
CRAZY NOW THAT I'M ON MY SOAPBOX
AS IT USED TO BE, EVEN THE
PRO-CHOICERS WOULD ADMIT THAT
ABORTION WAS AN UGLY THING.
BUT THEY FELT LIKE IT HAD T